the State Department is now warning
Americans to avoid all international
travel those currently out of the
country have been urged to return
immediately but it's not that simple
according to Americans stuck in Peru and
Morocco they had police guarding the
gates and said they don't have to try to
talk to them and they said you know all
the flights are canceled you can't come
in unless you have a ticket for tonight
we're really relying on media at this
point to show that there are US citizens
that are desperately trying to get home
this comes as FEMA is taking charge of
the federal response to the corona virus
only on CBS this morning FEMA
administrator that's Peter Gaynor joins
us to discuss good morning to you mr.
Gaynor president gale how are you I'm
okay I'm okay we're all worried about
everybody else
president Trump says he's now fully
engaged at the highest level that FEMA's
fully engaged so what specifically what
specifically rather is FEMA doing to
help yesterday we began to take over for
full operations coordinating the entire
federal effort right here in the
National Response Coordination Center we
combined secretary Azar's
operation center that's the sock here
yesterday so all of government is under
one roof where social distancing and
where throughout the entire building
with teleworking to make sure that we
can do this or respond to this virus and
in the long haul because it's gonna be a
long battle there what's your top
priority and what specifically are you
does this mean when you said we're all
together under one roof what are you
guys doing
well my top priority is protecting my
workforce and protecting the American
people so I gotta do both at the same
time the second priority is making sure
that we can respond to the coronavirus
like we ought today and we need to do
that for the long haul
we have many priorities that we're
working on today to include supply chain
management making sure we get those
requests filled by governors across the
country and many many other things that
we're trying to on
and make better connections mr. Gaynor
we're used to seeing FEMA providing
supplies and and shelter in in natural
disasters are you equipped to handle a
pandemic we are we're ready every day so
whether it's a pandemic or it's a
hurricane FEMA is ready and it's just
not FEMA it is really the whole of
government I have at my disposal every
single federal agency partners
commercial partners there's nothing in
my way from coordinating and and we're
ready for today and when we want to be
ready for where we are in two weeks and
we're ready for a natural disaster so
we're doing both things simultaneously
mr. Gaynor could you put a little more
meat on these promises and these
specifics here what kind of equipment
our supply chain management are you
working on I mean let's take testing for
example we know that tests need to be
distributed more people need to take
them are you coordinating that effort we
are along with my medical expertise
partners HHS we're working on everything
from testing kits to swabs to PPE you
name it
it when it's in demand it's in demand by
every single governor across the United
States we're trying to make sure that we
have a way to prioritize needs based on
request based on risk based on we think
where it's going to be today and where
we think it's gonna be tomorrow so all
those things are factors there's enough
heartbreak to go around we've all heard
the stories but in particular we did a
story here the other day Peter about the
health care workers that will break your
heart where they're saying we just don't
have the supplies we need to help the
people that need it is FEMA doing
anything to help them to make sure they
get everything that's available to them
well well again I think one of the one
of the best things we did is we combined
operations we tried to streamline the
process so whether it's a healthcare
director in a state or an emergency
management director in a state those two
things that combine so all those
resource requests are coming here to the
NRCC and we are validating and and
trying to fill every single need however
this is a shared responsibility it needs
to be locally executed state managed and
fairly supported the only way we're
going to beat this as we do it together
all right
female Minister Paul Gaynor thank you
very much for joining us this morning